Imamo prosopiske primude,
imamo pravna pravila,
to su ona pravila
koje imaju uređeno funkcionisani države
i omenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisani države
koja su pozvana čeo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti,
tu imamo državne grane
na različitom stepenu vlasti.
A kod koordinacije imamo isti
stepen vlasti i imamo saradit.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gdje smo sve zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Kada je reč o ljudima,
krenut ćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos.
prema državi kao organizaciju.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svojstavništvo.
Taj državni aparat čine
samo neki ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državni
u službenim licima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u ime za računom državu.
E sad, tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određene poslovi.
Zadrži imate određeno
državno službeno lice,
dajte mu da rade neki posao i taj
posao predstavlja njegovu naravljaju.
Ja se kudim dakle
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim.
Ne da se držim tih definicija izučbenika,
nego najprostije je moguće
da vam objasnim.
Uzmeš neki posao,
daš ga jednom državnom služnom oblicu
i dažeš evo ti na radi to.
To je tvoja nadležnost.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno
u radu državnih podana,
Ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službno novice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službno novice, da li oni radi isti?